[Music]
so there is a uh somebody dubbed the
brighton cat killer
who murdered at least nine cats and has
recently just died in jail oh
it was a really good oh that one's
called don't
that one messed me up so this this guy
killed nine cats and he went to jail for
killing cats he's a former a royal navy
gunner dubbed the brighton cat killer
after he carried out a string of deadly
attacks on pets right how did they know
that he killed the cats
well i mean like are they i mean so so
like is it like a seal killer that just
left the cat on the ground with like
quarters in the eyes or something oh he
had a signature signature thing you know
like yeah
he was jailed specifically in relation
to the deaths of nine casts and injuries
to seven more and he carried out this
deadly spree in east sussex between
october 2018 and may 2019 before finally
being captured on
cctv okay set up by the owner of a dead
feline damn
sting operator what does he have against
cats i know right because he probably
read online that to be a man you have to
be a [ __ ] killer so that's why he's
like
oh i'm a man
it looks like someone drew him yo he
looks like a condor
[Laughter]
no that's why this was so mad he looks
like that's like a bird you know he
looks like a cop he's like squidward he
looks like squidward in real life
real life squidward looking ass [ __ ]
oh my god that's what led him to cat
killing as he was bullied for his looks
we're all making fun of him still i
think so dude
i think if i look like that i would have
so much anger in my heart yeah and he
was a military dude too he was he was a
royal navy gunner the cause of his death
is not known but at his sentencing
hearing the court was told that he had
been diagnosed with thyroid cancer which
had spread to his liver and lungs oh man
i wish an inmate [ __ ] him up like
imagine there was like a uk thug yeah
he's a cat lover yeah
hella tattoos and cats all over right
and his gangster name is like kitty
[ __ ] kitty carlos
kitty carlos
kitty carl carlos and [ __ ] peter yeah
he rolls up to [ __ ] squidward and
slits his throat yeah like that'd be
tight yeah that's the revenge movie i
want to see bouquet his name was raised
by cats in the alley
the origin story yeah
i know it's cat man you know it's like a
uk thug
cat man you jailed for five years and
three months at hope crown court last
july after being found guilty of 16
offenses of criminal damage in relation
to the cats as well as possession of a
knife
wow okay he had served in the royal navy
for 22 years including in northern
ireland and iraq wow during his trial
jurors heard accounts from several cat
owners who had found their pets bleeding
on their doorstep oh my god
and we want to remember the cats so i'm
gonna give them their names nine cats
hendricks tommy hannah allen nancy gizmo
kyo ali and cosmo were killed and he put
them on their doorsteps of the owners
that's [ __ ] up you know let's put them
on that i didn't even catch them yeah
for real you must have been tracking
these cats thoughts aren't easy to catch
like a cat whisperer on top of it he
probably is [ __ ] loose what about
with food do they come with food like
you put like some food out there sashimi
cats are really really temperamental in
that way though so like they
they're either really used to human
beings therefore like they're down for
food yeah um aka being out and about or
if they're really domestic it's usually
they're like very uh they may allow
folks yeah
so as a cat guy when you read stories
like this are you extra like emotionally
charged honestly i i want to [ __ ]
make sure that this guy doesn't just die
and we don't remember his like uh
shittiness so i want to just make sure
that he doesn't just die quietly so
we're going to do a jk news episode
about him we're going to name the cats
we're going to give him their fair
justice and their life you know and
immortalize them yeah and then we're
going to remember this motherfucker's a
condor and squidward you know what i
mean he looks like a little [ __ ] you
know what makes me pissed
is he died of natural causes i think
what he should have done is dude we
should have taken him to a [ __ ] tiger
king
sanctuary
right
like trying to kill this big cat
go go ahead and be like hey dude like
why why you [ __ ] picking on the
little dudes for right and i'll tell
i'll be like hey [ __ ] tiger you know
what this [ __ ] did
yes
i'll be like hey tony the tiger it's
great
i'll be like you know what this [ __ ]
did he [ __ ] up all of your friends man
i have all of them i have a question for
all you guys do you guys think if we did
more poetic punishments to people that
like kill the cat we throw them in a
tiger pit do you think that would stop
crime or do you think that would just
make it worse
stop crying i don't think we'll ever
stop it stop it completely i think it
would slow it down
yeah i do think better punishments are
deserved media more entertaining i heard
north korea was really safe
[Music]
i don't know imagine this right imagine
imagine like let's say you're a gangster
you're a gangster with a daughter right
and you're doing drive-bys and if your
stray bullet hits someone else's
daughter they blast your daughter oh god
oh my god well let me let me let me give
you a nice can make you have a daughter
yeah well because some some people
they're like oh [ __ ] it i'll do i'll
i'll take it i'll go to jail like right
jail's not the problem it's not scary
the gangs are scary so like if if the if
the justice system is more of like uh
i don't know like a darker one
or whatever property a jomalian system
maybe so like so like if like a gangster
like you know a straight bullet like
kills a daughter maybe they not get
thrown into a jail that has like people
who had their daughters murdered oh okay
like that that's a good alternative
yeah so the other daughters doesn't have
to be killed
you know you hear about like how like
some some uh
jail communities and stuff prison
community and stuff like if a pedo walks
in they get like [ __ ] up yeah they
they beat the [ __ ] out but all these
people have like murdered raped and
stolen and [ __ ] but it's like a pedal
comes in we're gonna [ __ ] this full up
like there's some sort of weird justice
yeah yeah we gotta create pools of weird
jokes yeah yeah yeah yeah
like that lisa killed his daughter
you killed my daughter are you gonna
kill another person's daughter
that's a that's an eye for an eye i
don't have a daughter well your mother
was a daughter once yeah but because you
had that good like segway then we came
up with a better idea so it's all good
it's part of brainstorming it's just
neighborhoods in japan it's because they
have the highest gang members there
so like they're organized
you can't do petty crime like if if
you're an educator but you could do
organized crime yeah basically got it
got it but i mean like it's like if they
catch you because they want tourism and
they want like all the all the people to
spend money there at their businesses
right so if you're out there like
robbing pickpocketing all that stuff and
then the tourism like it kind of shuts
down right so you're [ __ ] with their
business so they're like [ __ ] up the
people that do petty crime on average
citizens so they're just the police
basically yeah oh the police is
organized like the underworld police
like they're uh it actually makes sense
because it's not like organized crime is
like petty crime i don't think anyone
likes like stealing [ __ ] robbery and
she like organized beating all ladies on
the street yeah like organized crime you
have brothels you have like if you want
to get drugs just stuff that
people do way more sophisticated yeah
gambling stuff that people do anyways is
just looked down upon morally but like
robbery and [ __ ] like um like like
destruction of property like that's just
a nuisance to both sides you know even
mafia don't like that [ __ ]
i like that where it's like okay we're
the police for the stuff that isn't
legal yet so don't [ __ ] with our [ __ ]
either which i think is tight yeah you
do some organized crime it's like cool
you kill a cat
[ __ ] no you need to die poetically
nobody likes cat killers yeah or animal
pet killers you gotta you gotta slit
their throat in the street bro who
hasn't seen don't [ __ ] with cats i
haven't
yo yo it's a good question it's so good
yeah
because first well that makes me buy a
cat though he already threw out a name
the first time i was watching it i
really thought it was just like oh don't
[ __ ] cast what the [ __ ] is this right
and then it doesn't i didn't think he
was gonna go into some like murder
mystery cereal type [ __ ]
but once it gets there yeah it's another
level that [ __ ] was so weird no
and that [ __ ] taught me that that
documentary was teaching me about like
internet sleuths
internet justice people that like they
just yeah they [ __ ] the crime and
then you start a forum and then you guys
actually figure this [ __ ] out i love
that she was cool about it though is
that how everybody was like got together
and kind of helped it's like that q and
on [ __ ] though but it's also like
sometimes not good because people start
making up [ __ ] most of the time
this is the rare case that it works
because the one in the the cecil hotel
one oh man oh that one was a [ __ ]
mess the way these people are like just
adding theories and it became this whole
thing when in reality it was just some
poor girl that like had a mental illness
detracted from the entire thing of like
ruined some other guy's life because
they thought he killed her that's also
when the police like put out the
evidence right so yeah that's why didn't
that guy kill himself too or something
no i don't oh i don't know i don't know
something like that yeah you talk about
the luca guy no no no no no
with the cecil hotel one it's like they
are like they like kind of semi-penned
it to like another dude who was like i
don't know if he's ex-military but he
like did paintball or some [ __ ] like
that but then that guy ended up getting
all these threats and stuff and then he
ended up offering himself yeah you know
what i mean he didn't kill himself he
was in the he was in the documentary are
you talking about the rock guy the rock
guy okay uh the twisted steel guy said
yeah i don't know anymore
we think he killed himself
[Laughter]
they all live among us all these people
we just never know we try to keep our
eyes open
if they look like squidward
yeah that's why we need more yakuza
justice man she loves yakuza here man
i don't love shopping we should bring it
to
this 626 area hell yeah that's the same
as joe being like north korea is safe
is safe dude i like them
[Music]